hi there steve kaufman here to talk once
again about language learning
and today i want to talk about the
importance of our sense of identity our
sense of who we are and i'm going to put
a link in the explanation or comment
section just below my video a link to an
article that appeared in the new yorker
magazine
which shows how
uh in order to try to persuade people
for example to persuade people that
vaccinations are good or to persuade
people of a political point of view it's
very hard to persuade people simply
based on facts
a much bigger part of it is
how these people identify if someone
identifies with a certain political
party or with a particular country then
you can present all the facts you want
about how this political party is bad or
our country did something bad and we
won't believe it we don't want to
believe it because it's crucial to our
sense of identity our sense of who we
are
and there are in this article you'll see
that there are a number of
experiments that have been done that
show
that different efforts to persuade
people of things if it doesn't attack or
if it doesn't deal with this core issue
of their identity then all these
arguments are
useless and in the same article there's
also reference to the fact that for
example in taking tests uh
as a positive affirmation an affirmation
you know i can do it
uh will influence the results or if
girls are convinced that girls are not
good at math and i'm a girl and that's
part of my identity
then i won't do well in the math exam
things like this now
this has real application for language
learning and i've always noticed it
in the book that i wrote almost 10 years
ago i refer to the importance of uh sort
of cultural weightlessness
the more we think we are unique and our
culture is unique and we're sort of tied
up in this whole sense of who we are
the more difficult it is to learn
another language because to learn
another language you have to
want to be one of them you have to
project yourself into that other
community
and i also mentioned a sort of an
anecdote when i was selling lumber in
japan
and we had a problem with our lumber
grades that the japanese felt or didn't
quite match the needs of the market so
we sent a
chief grader with 30 years of experience
working in a small town at the sawmill
we sent him to japan so he could better
understand the needs of the japanese
customers but of course he went there
with his identity of someone who had
graded according to the north american
grading rule for 30 years and he worked
his way up the ladder and this is what
this is who he was so rather than trying
to listen to
the customers how they wanted the lumber
graded he would lecture them on how we
did it
well one evening the customer took us
out to a japanese bar
and particularly in those days if you
went to a japanese bar you got a nice
little girl to sit beside you a little
girl like someone in their 20s cutie
and she would talk with you and tell you
how handsome you were and pour your
drinks and so forth
and of course i was there and i was
speaking japanese and this fellow
couldn't speak japanese and this girl
his girl said to him and do you speak
japanese and he'd had a few drinks and
he said no but i can learn
and that evening he had a great time
and don't read too much into it we all
went home after our few drinks there
but the next day because now all of a
sudden he had softened a bit he was
maybe a little happier to be in japan
felt a little less threatened his he
wasn't clinging to his identity as a
canadian lumber grader
and he started listening
and so it was again an example of this
whole importance of attitude and and our
sense of identity when it comes to
language learning
as i again i will repeat because it
bears repeating language learning is
based on only three things all the rest
doesn't matter it doesn't matter who
your teacher is who your grammar book is
whether you're on link or not on link
what matters is your attitude
you think you can do it you want to do
it
you like doing it the second thing is
time the amount of time you spend that's
going to depend on your attitude and the
third thing is developing that ability
to notice but that also depends on
attitude you have to want to notice
uh and so the sense of identity if
you're prepared
to not cling to your own identity and
i'm english-speaking north american and
therefore i'm not good at languages or
we japanese are so unique or any of
these kinds of things uh where you're
clinging to that identity and you won't
let go of that sort of
um
comfort
of that
what they call it safety blanket
so
identity is a big deal positive
affirmation but meaning it really
thinking that you are someone who can
operate in different cultures
you don't have to be in your own culture
you can enjoy other cultures you can
enjoy interacting with people of a
different culture you can learn another
language you like learning it all of
these kinds of things that relate to
attitude
but but really relate to this idea of
identity so
it's interesting how we as human beings
work we're not that rational
um you know uh
some of our belief systems are very hard
to dislodge
so read the article
i thought it was very interesting and
you'll see that it has application as
well for language learning and i look
forward to your own experiences in this
regard
and i thank you for listening bye for
now